نزل هالولد هذا انت من
مين وين بيتك يا عم
انت اي بيت البيت اللي انت فيه هذا اللي
انت واقف فيه
بيتك هذا البيت غه رمضان هذا البيت اللي
انت واقف فيه بيتك هذا
لايتو شوف هذا بيت اللي
[موسيقى]
جنبه
ظل بيت صالح للسكن ضل البيت غرفه
الضيوف ها الخزانه شايف الفراش في حد كان
نايم ه انا بقيت انا
مرتي
م ايش اللي صار بالضبط اللي صار انه قصفوا
دار
الحسنه بدون سابق انذار ولا بلغه انه ولا
اي حاجه الاشي صار فوق رؤسنا استشهدوا عنا
ثمانيه طب
هيك وين الشعوب العربيه وين شعوب العالم
اللي هي قاعده بتحكي بالديمقراطيه وبتحكي
انه اسرائيل مظلومه يا عم اسرائيل لازم
تروح على المحاكم الجنايات الدوليه احنا
مدنيين ايش احنا عملنا ايش الذنب اللي
ارتكبناه يصير الدمار هذا
عننا